-Former president
and allegedly current
presidential candidate
Donald Trump, once again,
lost his mind in a series
of unhinged social media posts
as the district attorney
investigating his attempt
to overturn the election results
in Georgia revealed in court
that she's close
to announcing decisions
regarding possible indictments
in the case
and even suggested
that there could be more
than one defendant.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
As you may recall,
in the days leading
up to the coup attempt
on January 6th,
Trump tried to pressure
Georgia's Republican secretary
of state, Brad Raffensperger,
to manipulate the vote tally
in Georgia
and overturn
Joe Biden's victory.
In particular,
there was that infamous line
where Trump just confessed
and told them
what he was asking for.
He wanted them to magically find
enough votes for him to win.
[ Laughter ]
Trump has the same energy
attempting a coup
as someone who's been
on the phone
with Verizon customer service
for an hour.
[ Laughter ]
"Look, all I want to do is this.
I just want to find, uh...
[ Laughter ]
Maybe Trump's pause was
because he didn't want
to sound suspicious,
asking for the exact amount
of votes he needed to win.
[ Laughter ]
He was trying to sound like it
was an arbitrary number
he pulled out of thin air.
[ As Trump ]
Look, this isn't even
about winning or losing, for me.
It's about getting
the count right
and, if we do that and Joe Biden
is still the winner,
I'll be the first
to congratulate him.
So, I'll just come up
with a number
off the top of my head --
[ Laughter ]
11,780!
[ Applause ]
That's, of course,
the most infamous line
from the phone call,
but the parts that remain
truly astounding to me
are all the deranged
conspiracy theories
Trump unfurled over the course
of an hour-long rant,
including stuff he admitted,
during the call,
may not be true.
Here are a few highlights,
in case you managed to block all
of this from your memory
and move on with your life,
in which case, congrats.
[ Laughter ]
Oof! It makes me feel bad
for Raffensperger.
He must've that same
feeling I get
when I take an Uber
to the airport
and, within two minutes,
the driver locks eyes on me
in his rearview mirror and says,
"So, you uh,
ever listen to Alex Jones?"
[ Laughter ]
There's so much to unpack here,
starting with Trump's insistence
that dead people are voting.
Now, of course, what he means is
people use dead people's names
to fraudulently vote --
which also didn't happen --
but he's too scatterbrained
to explain it that way,
[ Laughter ]
so it just sounds like he thinks
an army of zombie Biden voters
[ Laughter ]
cost him the election.
Trump then went on to say this.
[ Laughter ]
Anytime you say the words,
"This may or may not be true,"
[ Laughter ]
and those words
are immediately followed
by "They're burning ballots,"
it's definitely not true.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, most of Trump's
conspiracy theories,
I can at least trace back
to some tiny kernel of truth
that his diseased mind
then twisted
into some elaborate fantasy,
but this one,
I honestly have no [bleep] clue
where he got it from.
[ Laughter ]
And, interestingly,
we never heard about it again.
I mean, burning ballots?
Did he go to a magic show
and think it was
a polling place?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] You know,
they're burning the ballots
and then the ballots disappear.
They go poof, gone,
or so it seems.
[ Laughter ]
But then they pull the ballot
out of a hat
and you think,
"It can be the same ballot."
[ Laughter ]
But then, then they say,
"Is this your ballot?"
And, sure enough, it is.
It is your ballot.
[ Laughter ]
And then they take out
a big suitcase
and they stuff a lady into it
and they chop her in half.
[ Laughter ]
It's very sad.
They chop her in half
and then she gets
to vote twice --
once for the head
and once for the legs.
[ Laughter ]
Because, now, she's
legally two people,
two people who both vote
for Joe Biden,
which is very suspicious.
[ Laughter ]
Very suspicious and very sad.
But also, can we can we go
back to this?
[ Laughter ]
No, I can't believe that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Slow-motion instant replay
is such an old person way
of saying it.
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like the name
of a segment
on "America's Funniest
Home Videos."
"Now, let's check out the
slow-motion instant replay
of Dad taking a soccer ball
in the groin.
And, oh!
That's got to hurt!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, in all fairness,
that's not the face Rudy makes
when he's hit in the balls.
That's the face he makes
every time he remembers that,
by being
Donald Trump's attorney,
he's -- to use the legal term --
getting hit
in the balls every day.
[ Laughter ]
For example,
the district attorney
in Fulton County, Fani Willis,
has been investigating
this phone call
and the pressure campaign
around it,
to the point where she's
subpoenaed, among others,
Senator Lindsey Graham;
former Trump campaign counsel
Jenna Ellis;
and Rudy Giuliani.
In fact, Giuliani was informed,
last year,
that he's a target
of the investigation
and he was also called
to testify
before the grand jury in August.
-President Trump's former
lawyer Rudy Giuliani
faced a grilling for six hours
before a grand jury
in Atlanta yesterday.
Giuliani testifying as a target
of the criminal probe looking
into possible 2020
election interference there.
-We do know that it very likely
centered around statements
that Giuliani made to Georgia
lawmakers back in 2020,
just on the heels
of the presidential election,
where he came forth and made
a number of false claims
and, really, conspiracy theories
about the election here
in Georgia.
-What kind of charges,
potentially, would that mean?
-You know, the DA here
in Fulton County has indicated
that this could lead
to possible charges ranging
from racketeering
to possible conspiracy charges.
-Racketeering makes sense.
Conspiracy does, too,
but it might be a harder sell
to a jury
because Rudy is so bad
at conspiracy.
He literally holds up
incriminating texts on TV.
[ Laughter ]
He meets with shady characters
in cigar bars
and then takes pictures.
[ As Giuliani ]
Remember, fellas,
we never had this conversation.
Now, how about a quick picture,
so we never forget it?
[ Laughter ]
Also, my sympathies
to the grand jury members
who had to sit there and listen
to Rudy Giuliani for six hours.
And that probably feels like
12 hours to Rudy
because, as we discovered
during a recent
disciplinary hearing conducted
via Zoom,
he sometimes wears two watches
by accident.
[ Indistinct conversation ]
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if I'm Rudy's attorney,
that's my entire defense.
[ Laughter ]
I'll just let the prosecution go
for weeks on end,
building a case that my client
committed conspiracy.
When it's my turn, I'd stand up,
face the jury, and say,
"He didn't know he had
two watches on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Uh, the defense, uh, rests."
So, that's where
the investigation stood
until yesterday,
when Willis appeared in court
for a hearing on whether to make
the grand jury's report public.
Willis asked the judge to keep
the report private, for now,
and she did so
for a tantalizing reason.
She said she was
about to announce decisions
about indictments in the case
regarding multiple
potential defendants.
-New tonight --
The district attorney
in Fulton County, Georgia,
which includes much of Atlanta,
says her decision on charges
in the probe
of former President Trump's
efforts to overturn
the 2020 presidential election
is imminent.
-Fulton County DA Fani Willis
has asked the judge
to keep the report under seal,
citing concerns
for "future defendants."
-We think, for future defendants
to be treated fairly,
it's not appropriate,
at this time,
to have this report released.
We are asking that the report
not be released
because you haven't seen
that report.
Decisions are imminent.
-Now, I gave up,
a long time ago,
predicting whether Trump
will ever be indicted,
since he seems to wriggle
his way out of every jam
he's ever been in,
which is surprising,
given that he has
the flexibility
of a Mr. Potato Head
that got dropped in the toilet.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at him.
Why is he only capable
of bending at the waist
like that?
[ Laughter ]
He looks like one of those
drinking birds.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I will say,
if there are going
to be any indictments
in this case, at all,
you would assume that one
of them would be the guy
who made the phone call,
unless, of course,
Trump made a plea deal
and turned on Rudy.
[ As Trump ]
It was Rudy's idea.
We were having a sleepover
[ Laughter ]
and he said, "Let's do --
Let's do some prank calls."
And I said, "I don't know, Rudy.
We might get in trouble."
[ Applause ]
And he said,
"It'll be hilarious.
Let's call Georgia and tell them
dead people are voting."
[ Laughter ]
He did all the talking.
I just did background boos.
[ Laughter ]
I did -- I did spooky noises.
Of course, Trump didn't make
a plea deal.
In fact, the case sent him
into a tailspin and prompted him
to go nuts on his fake Twitter
rip-off, Truth Social.
Trump wrote,
among other things...
[ Laughter ]
I love that his argument is,
"If I was so crazy,
how come they didn't
hang up on me?"
Because you were the [bleep]
president, dude!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I know it's crazy,
but it fully happened.
[ Laughter ]
But just because you
were president
doesn't mean you were,
all of a sudden, making sense.
You were just too important
to hang up on.
If people could hang up
on the president,
don't you think "Fox & Friends"
would've done that
[ Laughter ]
during one of your rambling,
hour-long phone calls,
instead of staring
at you dead-eyed,
like tourists watching two rats
hump on the subway?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, if they had
hung up on you,
I'm pretty sure you would've
made a big deal about that, too.
You don't strike me
as the type of guy
who hears a sudden dial tone
and looks inward.
[ English accent ]
Oh, dear! They've...
hung up on me. I...
hope I didn't say anything
to offend.
[ Laughter ]
Also, they did tell you,
multiple times,
on the call,
that you were wrong.
In fact, my favorite example
of that was when Trump was asked
about some video he claimed
to have seen, supposedly showing
that Biden ballots
were scanned more than once,
which prompted Raffensperger
to say he would send Trump
a link to the real video
debunking Trump's claim.
[ Laughter ]
-I ha-- Mr. President --
"I have a --
I have a much better link"
is such a snotty
little thing to say,
while also fundamentally
misunderstanding
the technology
of what a link is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump is not technologically
proficient.
[ Laughter ]
Do you want the Wi-Fi password?
[ As Trump ]
No. I've got my own Wi-Fi,
got my own links.
[ Laughter ]
Got my own Wi-Fi,
got a couple of loose URLs.
We know what that stands for --
U R Losers.
[ Laughter ]
Not me.
I'm not a loser.
I got the good links.
[ Laughter ]
We obviously don't know
what happened in this case,
but it's clear, from the public
evidence, alone,
that Trump tried to commit
election interference
and coerce a public official
into manipulating votes.
And he got help from a bunch
of his closest cronies,
including Rudy.
Decisions about indictments
could come any day, now,
although they could happen
at different times
for different people,
so, if you're keeping track
of both Trump and Rudy,
you might need...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]